David Hasselhoff has some catching up to
do but let me just tell you this he is
obsessed with Facebook live right now in
connecting with his fans here's my
question though is he willing to walk
down the aisle in the first-ever
Facebook live celebrity wedding we are
off and running we can say whatever we
want
there we go where do you draw the line
at sharing on Facebook well we were in
the jacuzzi - the other day we had to
cut it real quick Neely was a little
scared because I had a very small speedo
on that would be Haley Roberts 63 year
old David's camera-shy 36 year old
fiance
finding someone that's not been in show
business it was from a small town in
Wales was a real lucky move for me just
found out some people got married down
there maybe we will - is there any
chance that you all would do maybe a
Facebook live wedding yeah you know we
could probably make a lot of money why
don't you talk to ET the answer is no
that would be a very private thing but
not much else is we're live on 8 a David
on Facebook live talking to his fans
live all over the world hello from good
old Germany hello from France
hey where's I went on this thing one day
and just started talking I went wow this
is kind of therapeutic the first one was
a snake was right yeah it was the snake
the way it was right there did you run I
have people saying don't kill it keep it
alive I'm not gonna kill this thing
bring him in bring him in David is not
afraid of showing off a pretty nice
lifestyle the great house traveling the
world here we are at the Fairmont Hotel
on
leaving downtown London but there are
headlines that have him claiming only
$4,000 in liquid assets while trying to
lower his spousal support to ex-wife
Pamela Bach you were saying that you
were having a tough time financially
sometimes you're up sometimes you're
down and I always laughing about all
these people that made all this money
and lost it and I said how could that
happen to them and all of a sudden I
woke up one morning and went oh I
realize now it's not about how much
money you have it's about living your
life I'm not gonna change my lifestyle
I'm not gonna change no matter what you
know I'm happy don't believe everything
you read everything is cool
see you later by the way the Hoff has a
lot going on he's got an 80s album that
he's working on and on his birthday next
month he will relive all his favorite
Knight Rider episodes on the El Rey TV
network